hello everyone and welcome to the
continuation of the match with anand
versus magnus carlsen from the round
five of the norway chess 2022 it's not
actually a match it's really a game but
if the classical game ends up in a draw
then the uh
armageddon game is played so if more
than one game is played i guess it does
make it a match
i'm calling it a match
so we will have a repetition of the
opening from the classical game but
only briefly uh things will get crazy
very quickly you guys will see what i
mean by this let's uh check it out so on
and uh with the white pieces opens with
e4 we have e5 by magnus knight f3 knight
to c6 and bishop to c5 uh c4 so yeah the
italian game sim is in their classical
game knight to f6 magnus replies with
the two knights defense and the d3 and
here
in the classical game magnus went for
the bishop to e7 line but here he goes
for bishop to c5 and those two are
pretty much equally played um they are
the two to two main continuations
against this um d3 line uh bishop to g5
as now the bishop is not on e7 so it
makes sense the developer bishop to g5
and now usually uh black will just play
h6 here uh but magnus plays bishop back
to e7 so this um bishop to c5 to e7 is
an incredibly rare continuation uh i
don't even know if it's uh real uh but
magnus plays it and he wants to confuse
on and very very early on so here are
knights to c3 on continuous development
d6 and now pawn to a4 so just very very
standard moves castles and now uh pawn
to a5 and this is now a new move uh
there is a game where mikhail antipov um
uh played h3 against sergey karjakin uh
in the 2020 russian championship where
karakin was able to win that game but
here after a5 uh it is already as of
move eight that we have a completely new
game so the magnus playing the weird uh
bishop the c5 to e7 maneuver but it is
anand who creates a completely new game
and okay bishop to g4 magnus develops
the bishop h3 and he gives up the bishop
for knight captures captures and now
knight to d4 an active square for the
knight forcing the queen to go back to
guard the the c2 pawn so on and place
queen back to d1
c6 we are uh preparing the the uh b5
pawn push
and now on under just castles we have b5
and now you would expect a capture some
b6 alpha saw uh but anand just brings
the bishop back bishop to a2 we have
knight back to e6 charging the bishop
here and bishop back to e3 so anand
keeping the bishop fair for the moment
with a6 of course the pawn cannot be
captured if you capture the point you
just blunder a piece because the rook
would be attacking the queen so i hope
none of you were looking at that pawn so
here pawn to a6 and the queen to f3
developing the queen connecting the
rooks we have queen to d7 by magnus he
does the same and now knight to e2
preparing the standard c3 and then we
are going to push stuff uh magnus says i
will start pushing before you he says d5
we have c3 and now bishop to c5 offering
a trade of dark square bishops e
captures on d5 c captures and now bishop
captures on c5 we have knight captures
and d4
uh challenging carson's knight and c5
but it would be silly to just move the
knight without first grabbing more space
in the center so this is exactly what
magnus does queen to e3 and now knight
to d3 and here magnus has a beautifully
placed knight on d3 at targeting the b2
pawn so anand goes back queen to d2 and
now rook ate the e8 and uh we could say
that magnus is enjoying his position
very very much
but anand says your knight is very
nicely placed on d3 but maybe we can
undermine it
f3 now of course if you capture i'm just
going to capture
the knight here
and
here magnus finds a beautiful move
knight to f2 what kind of a move is that
well he's saying uh if you capture i'm
just gonna capture back with this knight
because if you capture the knight i'm
just gonna play e3 in the wind material
here so uh here we have f captures on e4
and magnus just picks up the pawn back
knight two captures on e4 attacks the
queen queen to d3 and now queen to d6
and now controlling the the g3 square so
it's very hard to activate this knight
uh rook to f3 and preparing rook a to f1
and now pawn to g6 we have rook a to f1
and not knight to h5 now really
controlling a lot of squares here f4 and
g3 very nicely controlled also this
knight controls the f2 square uh so here
g4 and
has to get rid of this knight knight
back to f6 and now knight to f4
we have knights the g5 by magnus
attacking the rook putting pressure on
the h3 pawn and rook 3 to f2 and here we
have knight g back to e4 and this is a
move uh magnus played probably because
he has the black pieces in armageddon
he's trying to see if vishu will go just
knight f3 knight g5 knight f2 knight to
e4 but of course he's not gonna do that
if the game ends up in a draw then black
wins the game in armageddon so here uh
anand plays a rook back to g2 and now we
have pawn to h6 we have h4 you have to
push you have to win
g5 attacking the knight captures
captures now comes knight to h3
attacking the g5 pawn king the g7 now
magnus says i might even use the open h
file to attack the white king and now
rook to f5 here anand goes after the g5
pawn and magnus just plays rook to h8
which is the correct idea
uh but here's the the interesting part
here we have knight captures on g5 just
grabbing that pawn and now magnus uh
well there is a move that magnus should
play magnus should play knight captures
on g5 and after real captures with king
of f8 and black is perfectly fine here
you have the e file all to yourself you
have the h file all to yourself the
knight is very strong the queen is very
strong
so black would be better here however
after knight captures on g5 magnus
played rook to h4 now putting pressure
on the g
wow on the g4 pawn but now the position
is winning for anand but only if you
find one particular move that wins the
game so feel free to pause the video and
win the game for anand while i give you
a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this move
as this is just an entire ocean of lines
that you have to calculate in order to
find this one and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is our
good friend the bishop captures on d5
yes it is that's the good stuff
uh so this is what hanan played and now
uh it's just uh
there's just no good move for magnus now
the pawn pawn is gone and the knight
here uh is is uh just being attacked
three times so you have to do something
about this and there's not all that much
you can do let's see what happens if you
just capture the bishop and i mean why
wouldn't you we're going to play knight
captures on e4 and now okay the queen is
attacked you also have to keep an eye on
the knight we're going to play queen to
e6 not just queen to d2 now we are
planning queen g5 check now the rook
will hang so queen the h6 you have to
defend there's no good way to defend
against uh to defend the knight on d5
and to prevent queen to g5 so that's
just it let's say you play some like
queen h6 queen g5 check even captures
captures with checking has to move we're
going to capture the knight here
and that's just it not all that much
can be
done here or you can even go knight to
d6 attack this rook and after let's say
knight to f4 attacking the rook we can
even go into this knight capture 78
knight captures on g2 captures captures
and now we are up two pawns this is of
course a completely winning endgame for
white so that's what happens if knight
captures on d5 on the other hand you
could also play the tricky knight
captures on c3 which is too much a bit
uh to calculate for an armageddon game
but it's a nice line so we're going to
discuss it uh saying that okay i win
back the pawn and then i'm going to
capture on d5 but anand would say nope
knight captures an f7 and now what do
you play your queen is queen is hanging
there's just not a good move let's say
rookie one check king f2 now queen e7 uh
makes sense you want to play rook to h1
uh we're just gonna play rogue g5 check
and after king to f8 now comes knight to
e5 and this is just resigns now you uh
you've disconnected the queen's defense
of the rook so king captures rook is a
threat knights the g6 with this monster
royal fork also a threat so there's just
no playing this so those are only some
of the lines that uh
are happening after bishop captures on
d5 and i've shown you the ones that are
actually good for black so here magnus
instead wins for knight captures and g5
it is the absolute best line for black
but now after this move we have rook
captures and g5 with cher king the f8
and now comes the bishop back to f3 and
here uh anand allows magnus to bounce
back and uh go back into the game
because here the move you had to find
was queen to g3 this just forces an end
game and that's a winning end game for
anand because you force a queen trade as
the queen and the rook are hanging so
here you would have to trade captures
captures and the end game of course is
completely winning for for white you
would still have to play for it but you
are up to pawns of course anand will win
this so instead anand played bishop to
f3 but now magnus
has a chance we have queen to f4
and now rook to e5
uh if you go for d5 let's say you just
push a pawn then rook to e1 with jerk
king to f2 rook hd h1 and that's just
terrible
there's just no playing this knight to
e4 and of course white resigns so you
have to be careful anand plays
rook to e5 he has to give up a pawn to
survive this he cannot allow rook to e1
check so rook captures pawn captures
queen captures and now king the f2 not
allowing the queen to infiltrate via the
e file and now magnus has to play rook
to h1 and it's such a fine move to see
on the board threatening queen to e1
checkmate but instead magnus plays rook
to h3 now he paralyzes the bishop the
queen is here and of course uh it's also
a very unpleasant move to see but he
allows anand counterplay g5 uh not just
counter play but uh grabbing a better
position knights the h5 again rook to h1
is always possible to throw in because
uh
it comes with the threat of checkmate
but magnus plays knight to h5 and now
anand plays g6 and now you can no longer
play rook to h1 if you play rook to h1
now now the problem is queen d8 check
and after the king moves g captures on
f7 comes with check and after king moves
bishop d5 check the king has no squares
uh all of the squares are taken you will
have to capture the bishop and now we
just win the game easily so here after
g6 what you have to find is queen to c5
check but magnus was incredibly low on
time he missed this move the idea is of
course
you can't just go anywhere this is taken
by the rook this is covered by the queen
so you have to be if you go king to f1
for example rook to h1 check king e2 and
on knight to f4 just uh completely
blunders the game for white so what you
would have to find after queen to c5
check is actually just blocking with
queen to d4 and here we would trade
captures captures and now the game
continues with uh uh magnus having
chances to save the game however after
this g6 move magnus played f captures
and g6 and now just queen to d8 with
check this is the only winning move and
anand finds it we have queen to e8 we
have traits captures captures and the
rook captures on g6 and now how are you
guarding the queen side pawns we have
knights to f4 now comes rook captures on
a6 knight to d3 check going after the
pawn here uh but uh
uh ananda doesn't go after the rook
anand plays the tricky king the e3 and
he traps magnus um
in a sort of a trap it's not a real trap
because you could still capture on
b2 and continue playing the game
although after rook to a7 completely
cutting off the king moving the rook and
pushing the a pawn uh this would just be
winning for white however uh here after
this knight
king to e3 move uh knight to e5 was
played and we reached the position from
the thumbnail now it seems like magnus
is winning the bishop here but magnus
completely missed that
rook the e6 check picks up the knight
and he was in this position on move 50
that magnus calls and resigned to the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here plus he had like zero seconds on
the clock uh so i don't even know how
this move was played but it was
uh so yeah uh that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it the brilliant brilliant
uh showing by anand uh as he had a
winning position against magnus in
classical and then uh he was able to
beat him uh on demand in armageddon with
the white pieces so incredible stuff of
course as the magnus and and went into
round five being tied now on and again
uh takes the lead in in the tournament
which is incredible i mean you you you
lead the tournament and in round five
you face magnus and then you beat magnus
and that i i i think that's just an
amazing result and that uh well now now
uh really he has to take it all the way
so we'll see what happens it's a it's a
crazy crazy event uh hope you guys are
are enjoying this short coverage uh so
yeah that's the game uh i hope you guys
enjoyed it of course now you lose the
knight and there's no point in
continuing the game so that's why magnus
resigned uh i would like to thank varun
sudarsanan richard knapp raymond young
assad simmons and david kimura for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
norway chess tournament until it
finishes so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day